I have never really been worried about
whether something was trivial or not
uh well no that's not true I was worried
you know in my early 20s let's say
uh people always thought that I would
you know be a great mathematician and be
good at various things and so on and in
my late 20s I hadn't achieved any of the
things that people were predicting
and so I call it my black period I
started to wonder you know whether it
was all nonsense whether I was not a
good mathematician after all and so on
and then I made a certain Discovery and
um was shot into International
prominence as a mathematician
when you become a prominent
mathematician in that sense
it doesn't mean that many people know
your name it means that many
mathematicians know your name and there
aren't many mathematicians in the world
anyway you know so it doesn't count very
much but it's suddenly
released me from feeling that I had to
live up to my promise you know I had
lived up to my promise I sort of made a
vow to myself
it was so nice not worrying anymore that
I thought
I'm not going to worry anymore ever
again I was going to study whatever I
thought was interesting and not worry
whether this was serious enough
and most of the time I've kept to that
well and what has that resulted in for
you what has has that made you better or
more successful or just happier what's
the result of taking that attitude
uh well it made me happier yes it made
me happy is the only one of those
different things
uh
I you know I sit in a corridor in the
mathematics Department in Princeton
and I think about things
and I imagine that the young graduate
students think oh this guy's a loony he
did something good once
and I don't care I really don't care
I've been released from worrying about
what other people think about about me
and in a way he did do something
interesting once
you know if I may say that
um and as far as I'm concerned I'm doing
something interesting right now I don't
mean talking to you I'm sorry that's
really boring forgive me for saying that
but um uh no I I find some problem
I try and solve it
and I don't care whether it's a problem
that will advance my reputation or not I
mean I really don't do you care about
I've been freed knowledge advancing
mathematics
yes I suppose I do but less than I did
before because you know I'm pretty old
now and so if I Advance mathematics and
I'm not around to see the result of that
advancement
and what do I care
um I don't know I don't like thinking of
my impending death
um
and uh
you know I haven't got all that many
years left I don't quite know how many
but I do still like doing mathematical
things so I do do you ever feel
frustration that you won't see where
things are going to be in 50 years or
the next breakthrough do you worry about
the things you'll miss
uh no I don't think I do I mean you see
uh a whole series of things have
happened you know when I was
a kid and I mean a sort of late teenager
and learned about all these unsolved
problems
it really did seem there were about four
of them there was a Four Color map
theorem there's firmer's Last Theorem
the human hypothesis the Continuum
hypothesis okay
and they had all lasted at least 100
years
um and it looked as though they were
going to last another few hundred years
you know and then they've mostly been
solved in some sense Continuum
hypothesis solved in a way
Four Color Maps theorem definitely
solved but um
the human hypothesis is still unsolved
I've forgotten what the fourth one was a
female solved yes of course
um so three out of the four were solved
or should we say two and a half out of
the four because the solution of the
Continuum hypothesis
is a bit different from the others but
um there's a very definite sense in
which it is solved
and that may be the only sense in which
one can live with it so to speak
but they had all lasted at least 100
years
now when something lasts 100 years
you're unlikely to be in in it at the
beginning and at the end of it that
demands that you're at least 100 and say
17 years old provided you're pretty
bright at the age of 17. so essentially
nobody uh is in at the beginning and the
end and so we're accustomed really in
mathematics to have these problems that
you don't expect to see solved in your
lifetime
um
there's nothing you can do about that I
mean
you can wail and moan and say you know
something I've heard people say that if
if they are granted they think to come
back in a few hundred years you know
what's the first question you'd ask some
of them say has the so-and-so problem
been solved you know
um but really there's nothing you can do
you can try desperately to solve it but
if it hasn't been solved for a hundred
years you probably aren't going to
um you know it's only given to one
person so to speak to solve a particular
one of these problems
so we're used to it and here's an
atmosphere of resignation you know
there's also a thing that we don't
really know quite often
whether a problem can be solved I have
to ask you then if you will if you come
back in a few hundred years and get one
question what's your question then
yeah interesting
uh this is not original I mean uh I'd
like to know whether the agreement
hypothesis have been solved and
and so on and perhaps a few more
technical details about it
um but that's not an original thought
with me so do you have unfinished
business were there things you wanted to
crack or do that yeah you haven't done I
know you still could do it but do you
have unfinished business uh
I don't know that I have I mean I have
unfinished business in a way things I'd
like to do but I'm not going to do them
I'm not going to solve them there's one
thing I would really like to know yes
perhaps if I hark back to the question
you asked a little bit ago there's a
thing called the monster Group which is
a beautiful very large symmetrical
thing
and I would just like to know what it's
all about
uh
you know why it's there and every now
and then I I've often said I've said for
25 or 30 years that the one thing I'd
really like to know before I die is why
the monster group exists
I'm resigned now to not learning it
before I do I might just every now and
then I've taken it out so to speak
thought about it for a time it's about
every five years except I haven't done
it for 10 there's never been any kind of
explanation of why it's there and it's
obviously not there just by coincidence
it's got too many intriguing properties
for it all to be just an accident
so what's that number again
196 883
that's the dimension of the space it
lives in Center arbitrary
oh no it's not a harbor tree oh
no it's got to be 196 000 days 183 yes
47 times 59 times 71.
9-0 is on the end so this is
approximately uh eight times ten to the
53.
okay that's the size of the monster this
is pretty difficult it's quite quite a
difficult thing to try and explain I
think I've done this Christmas tree
ornaments
um you can hang
you know sometimes you see a Christmas
tree ornament which has a number of
spikes coming out of it